so again your alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants
well yeah if you say it like that it
don't sound believable oh hey captain
did you get my report on the Finley
murder oh yeah looks it over nice work
good thanks dad why is everyone staring
at me you just called captain hold dad
he said thanks dad
what no I didn't I said thanks man do
you see me as a father figure Peralta no
if anything I see you as a father figure
cuz you're always bothering me
hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him dad no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once and she's
my fiancee guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling hope daddy hey daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that had he admitted that
his alibi was a lie it was a trap
all part of my crazy devious plan I
believe you
thank you son you want to talk about it
later over a game of catch
[Music]
okay detectives let's get started
Santiago where are we with the Jay
Street drug busts are 12 keys of coke
unaccounted for but we just got a
warrant to search the Taylor's apartment
good take Boyle and Diaz Dream Team
Peralta
brief us on the vandalism case well
there's no easy way to put this Sarge
but someone has been painting wieners on
squad cars and apparently they won't
stop until there's a penis drawn on
every cop car in Brooklyn that's what
he's been drawing but what are those two
little round things at the bottom it's a
button what I assume you have a plan to
catch this gentleman did you just say
gentlemen because if so kudos and yes I
have a plan I'm gonna plant a decoy
squad car as bait
meanwhile I'll be waiting in an
undercover vehicle here
he's already tagged three you see
vehicles you can clearly spot him you
should take my minivan a minivan you all
got a problem with my minivan my wife
doesn't like it either she wanted an SUV
but those things roll man
they roll it's a good idea sergeant
we'll take the van we you're coming with
me
sir with all due respect I don't need
backup it's not backup it's babysitting
well the curse is over the slump is done
Jake is back permission to take a selfie
of the two of us sir permission denied
too late that was a good one so the
rabbit's foot worked huh yeah maybe all
I know is my mind was so numb from doing
all that boring data entry that my brain
kind of rebooted and I had an
inspiration about one of my old cases
and I now see that that was your plan
all along
and that you're capable of smiling all
talented detectives have their ups and
downs Peralta so you think I'm talented
you said it no take-backs you know what
Boyle doesn't slump because his whole
life is a slump because he doesn't light
adversity get him down he keeps grinding
if I'd given you those new cases the
second you hit a snag he would have
spiraled again you need to stay out of
your own head okay but sir I don't get
it if that was your plan why bother with
Smitty and the rabbit's foot well
there's a very good reason to that I
I believe the term is messing with you
oh I see what's going on here we're
becoming homies office Christmas card
candidate right here being hold your
homies boy where's my paperwork on that
deal wait still waiting on the autopsy
report supposed to come in first thing
this morning but so far nothing this is
unacceptable
I'll call the ami and find out what
happened that's not necessary sir for
the record I think it's natural causes
anyway but I'm also the secondary on
this case it's my responsibility so I
will head on down there pick up the
report good but don't ever pop up about
me again right I don't know
buh-buh-buh-buh just go yep I am going
to regret teaching him that one thank
you money was still in the bookies safe
all the numbers match let's head back to
Sunday August party oh no thanks I think
I'm gonna head home and watch the
football game which was ruined for me
what's your problem with celebrating
Thanksgiving it's a sucky holiday it's
always sucked my mom worked my dad was
gone and I sat at home watching football
okay I came from a very formal family my
parents were not especially affectionate
really your honor wasn't a big snuggler
but the beauty of being an adult is that
you can make a new family with new
traditions well that's nice captain but
I don't have a new family yet so I guess
I'm stuck with my awesome old traditions
okay
I'll tell it squad you couldn't make it
thank you before you go can I borrow
some money and get some pretty serious
vibes from Wendy over there and I'd like
to take her someplace special
[Music]
all right my safe house my rules
a hungry safe house is an unsafe safe
house a fun safe house is a safe safe
house my sir doctor said you've never
played this it's very intuitive let's
have another sandwich a safe house
watchin safe house is a safe safe house
house I've already seen the film I
enjoyed it
Wow I would not have guessed that you
see those are the kind of things that
you learn when you're handcuffed
together and that is the true meaning of
Christmas
so the burner phone that Doug Judy used
to contact the Pontiac bandit is at his
mom's house he's agreed to help us catch
the Bandit if we drop all charges
against him
how many cars would you say this Pontiac
bandit is stolen two hundred and thirty
that I know of but the real number could
be in the millions you're not very good
at math hmm what are the charges against
doing 12 counts of identity theft but
I've been chasing him for a moment Oh a
month I've been trying to catch the
Pontiac bandit for eight years you know
any months that is a t14 six years
months do you need a math tutor because
the department will provide one for you
I can't tell if you're being serious
so captain I've been thinking about this
whole missing backpack thing and what if
we find Flaco and take him down
oh are you trying to solve CJ's case
behind his back to embarrass him no not
at all in fact I think CJ should come
along I just realized how important my
duty as a police officer is to me you
know the sacred oath I took your speech
really inspired me I know it's one of my
better ones
I felt really good as I was saying it
yeah so what's the plan huh well dad we
don't know where Flaco is but I have a
CI who says he's got an agreement with
Marco Severino so you think we should
pose as drug dealers looking for a new
heroin supplier and get Severino to hook
us up with Flaco then you think CJ can
handle this mission I know he's
inexperienced but he's a creative guy I
think he'd be great undercover well cam
muchachos let's roll up on these
muchachos great start and I love your
double use of muchachos hey it's CJ by
the way
super glue your pace your putts ladies
because Jake is in the house what
nevermind oh no Chuck I'm also worried
about you
come here Tim minute hug time I'd rather
not okay hmm Boyle release him fine only
because you're ordering me to there's
nine minutes left on that hug wait
it's ahead nice job and Quebec
I bet the local cops weren't happy you
show them up yeah well maybe not at
first
but by the end they kept calling me a
real bottle which I can only assume
means hero
it means bastard but that's only because
they were jealous you did good work here
is this an allowance are you giving me
an allowance no I'm paying the bartender
for more drinks all right Robbie
nine minutes start now good evening sir
no it's not I haven't slept because I've
been going over that stupid problem now
I finally understand Kevin's side cool
so it's all better and I never have to
hear about math again quite the opposite
I know better than ever how incorrect he
is probability doesn't kick in
throughout to teach you college-level
statistic I don't know do I have to
teach you high school statistics
throughout the teach you eighth grade
statistic do I have to teach you
seventh grade statistic do I have to
teach you now if you'll excuse me
detectives I need to leave him a slice
mail about kindergarten statistics okay
we have got to explain this thing to
captain Holt to save their relationship
and you laughed at me when I went to
that weekend long math conference
because you called it funky cats and
they're feisty Steph's
that was the name it was so cool it was
not anyway it's not about the math they
haven't seen each other because of the
night shift I just need a bone what
gross Rosa those are our dads I mean
that's not what I think captain dad is
just my boss Wow never mind I'm teaching
father the math whatever Rosa
[Music]